so what are the big questions that you
think our audience has in the down to
the wire minutes before christmas that
we're experiencing right now like what
are the big issues that shoppers want us
to help them navigate and ourselves
navigate well i think supply chain issue
first of all because that's a buzzword
that we've been hearing for months now
throughout this pandemic now to the
supply chain crisis seeming to get worse
each day i would say the biggest
challenge is really the health of the
supply chain we still have to keep
working at all nodes in the supply chain
have we done a good enough job covering
what exactly the supply chain issues are
well people like saying it but they
don't really know what it means what is
it it's basically the people and the
things that get us what we want from
point a to point b so if you want to buy
a jacket and you want to get it by i
don't know friday you have to understand
that that jacket is sourced in china the
material went there or is from there and
they're putting it together they're
stitching it together in china then it
has to go through customs through hong
kong or somewhere else and then it has
to make its way over to la then it has
to be transported over to new york
eventually and make it into the store
where you can then go pick it up and
with the labor shortage lots of
disruption monkey wrench in the works
completely because this used to be a
finely calibrated dance
and now it's been completely broken it's
like you know something someone stuck a
wrench right in the gears and it's been
broken at a time when we're being told
to spend more and also we just want to
spend more i mean this is the first pent
up demand pent up demand pent up demand
in general and just pent up frustration
with not being able to do what we want
to do and so people are like you know
2021 christmas uh hanukkah is the time
where i can kind of pretend things are
going back to normal and i want to do
what i want to do and i'm going to do
that by getting more and more and more
stuff prices are rising so yeah you're
going to probably spend more on things
but at the same time you have to buy for
the holidays you wonder if prices will
continue to go up even more so people
might be using this opportunity to buy
more of their stuff that they want later
on yes in hopes that they catch it now
before prices go up further in 2022.
that's what inflation brings like this
this need this urgency to spend now so
not only do we need to be buying just
because it's our first semi-normal
holiday since covet hit it's also that
if we don't buy everything now it's only
going to get it's only going to get
worse although there's a big debate here
about whether the inflation that we're
seeing is temporary or permanent in the
beginning
all these different policy makers
president biden jay powell the chairman
of the federal reserve all said it was
temporary it's transitory but you're
seeing that they're no longer using that
word because it's not clear i mean
covet's going to be with us for a long
time the disruptions to the supply chain
is going to be with us for a long time
and so prices are going up and companies
honestly once they raise prices it's
unlikely they're gonna cut it oh
absolutely right why would you go back
you're gonna see the price increases are
sticky meaning they're gonna stick
around for a while so that's gonna be
another issue i don't like what i'm
hearing right now and i feel like
consumers won't like it either we don't
want things to get more expensive we
love to buy we have not seen prices go
up in this kind of way in decades what
is it looking like compared to how our
spending power used to look like we
saved a lot of money during the pandemic
so people have a lot more disposable
income in fact if you look at the
savings rate it spiked during the
pandemic obviously government stimulus
checks helped because it provided a
cushion but now that we're kind of
reopening the economy again and people
feel more comfortable that is coming
down again spent spent spending time at
the same time
consumer spending household spending
drives this u.s economy it makes up 68
69 of our economy that's compared to 62
61 in the early 1960s in the 1980s and
1990s that line pretty much goes
straight up it's like when we really
perfected our ability to spend and
support the economy and what is it about
the us that makes us such spenders we
are very much an economy that's driven
by like support businesses and make sure
that there's enough jobs and our our
economy is built around you and me
buying things so if we don't buy enough
things if prices go down and we don't
want to buy things then companies will
notice and they'll produce less stuff
and then they produce my stuff then they
don't need as many workers they're going
to start firing workers the economy
slows down so if that's the cycle and if
cove is sticking around that tells me
this isn't temporary there's someone
from the opinion team who's done a lot
of reporting on this who i feel like
would be good for us to talk it can give
us a different perspective
but first ever wonder what happens to
all those items you return online we'll
visit a new store giving unused stuff a
second life
good morning
[Music]
so scarlet this is what you called the
ground zero of american over consumption
i feel like this comes full circle we
buy too much stuff online because it's
easy to do it then we return it and it
ends up in a place like bingers bargain
bins and i can't wait to see what's in
these bins battleface is ready let's do
it
[Music]
rob so exciting for you to have us here
can you explain what we're looking at
here what you are seeing here is what i
called
a gold mine
okay this is returns unused products
something that was probably in demand
highly on tick tock and then now no one
wants it anymore
whatever has left larger retail it comes
here
i definitely over order from online
retailers but how does that get from my
return to this location we have
relationships with restockers or
resellers and so before it gets to a
landfill of actually their warehouse it
and then we will actually purchase it
from them you grab it before it gets to
the that's the landfills
so you have different rates for
different days how does that work today
is friday 10 99 tomorrow saturday we go
down to 8 49
sunday 6 49 monday 3 49 and then tuesday
two items for 2.99
so wait that's when everything gets
cleared out completely so friday this is
all brand new stuff brand new
the treasure is getting into it and
digging i mean this is stuff you can use
there's clothes too my god
if there is inflation out there does it
affect how you guys do anything over
here whatever goes on outside this and
our prices will stay the same if you
constantly deliver consistency to
customers they're gonna come back that's
why they're here every week how many
items does each person tend to buy at
least 30 items 30
are these families are these people who
are going to resell these items some are
resellers but mainly the families are in
here everyone has a phone out and
they're okay this is worth this this is
worth that the smart consumers really
are here
i do feel like the key is the boxes if
you unbox you're going to find something
really good yeah what if you only want
to go for boxes yeah mystery box all
right i got to see this mystery
box come on
so the key here in these mystery boxes
is it delivers value you can get a
really good deal yeah even though you
don't know exactly what's in there yeah
absolutely
green light home theater portable led
protector nice makeup
makeup this is a good box
do you ever get the sense that you're
contributing to over consumption places
like this i think are wonderful because
it's it's given all of this product a
second life that would have ended up in
a landfill and it's given consumers a
place to get a really good value
how do you see yourself as different
from tj maxx or marshall if you don't
like it at 8 49 come in the next day on
tuesday when it's 299 and you're getting
something that's worth 40 dollars you're
paying what you want not what we're
demanding from you that doesn't happen
at t.j.maxx that doesn't happen anywhere
everyone wants a deal so can you show me
something where i'd be blown away by
what a great deal i'm getting absolutely
fitness watch here looks good steel we
have hair clippers oh that looks like a
good set and for the gamers
gaming headset ooh my son would like
that and this is all available for 10.99
today
i think we should put ourselves to the
test alright so let's do it how much do
we think this is 150. i'm gonna say
300.
actual retail value is 245. oh yes and
you can get that for ten dollars
oh my god i feel like if we go and dig
some more we're going to find some more
of our own let's do some more
this is so cozy i like this chair yeah
that's cute we'll cook makeup oh my god
there's so much selection
what's your tip for finding the most
expensive item people come on this day
because they know the best of the best
is out on a friday how many iphones are
going to actually show up in one of
these bins you'll be surprised really
and you you saw them coming in put them
in the bed
[Music]
okay mission accomplished we didn't need
a trolley we managed to haul it all i
know i got body bumpers i got masks for
all of us on the team for when we hold
up the royal mint incredible let's load
this stuff up all this loot
[Music]
so allison we were talking earlier about
how this holiday season we're dealing
with a couple of issues when it comes to
shopping supply chain issues of course
and you've got inflation as well and you
came up with this proposal which
probably got some people worked up
what did you suggest
um well as i said it's a provocative way
of putting the advice is that maybe we
should shop more like europeans rather
than buying a lot of stuff in bulk
that's low quality
that we buy fewer things that are higher
quality less frequently so we consume a
lot more than we used to our consumption
per capita has increased like 65 since
the 80s
and we're just buying a lot more stuff
it's low quality so when you see a chart
of our consumption as a percentage of
gdp it's gone pretty much straight up
especially during the 80s and 90s what
was happening during that time to enable
that a lot more trade particularly a lot
more trade with countries cheaper labor
like mexico and china which meant that
we got a lot of goods for a much lower
price and also there were technologies
like amazon that there's deflationary
pressure from that because you can
compare prices across a lot of goods see
remember in the 80s you'd have to drive
to a store or whatever you got price was
you kind of accepted it now on amazon
you can price compare and that puts more
pricing pressure on and you get it very
easily delivered to you so all these
things made consumption a lot faster and
a lot cheaper but i also want to take a
step back because
if we are to follow the european model
that's going to take a lot of
psychological work to shoppers like me
who this is our lifestyle so
what do we do to convince ourselves to
get on board with less for more quality
well buy things you really love
you know i said
there's some hesitation there is maddie
swallowed
it's just hard because like you know the
latest thing that's trending on tick
tock to wear out changes every day and
instead of affording the but do you
really love it 48 hours later no yeah so
buy something you truly love and you
will love forever and you'll wear until
it dies right right things that have
staying power i have a lot of things
that don't have staying power inside my
house i have a graveyard of humidifiers
i only bring that up because it wasn't
very expensive you know you talk about
low quality goods these are 20
humidifiers that once i realized i had
to clean them i decided it was too much
work i just got a new one so they're
just kind of lined up in my house same
thing with bags i have a lot of purses
where i wore them for like a year and
then i decided okay time for a new one
and they just kind of all hang off of my
bed post well it's like these shoes that
i bought for ten dollars on shein
because i thought for one second that i
was gonna want to wear heels at work
which i will never do i'll always wear
sneakers at work but you know now what
am i gonna do with these i feel guilty
about giving them away or ditching them
but so then they just sit in my closet
or under my desk compiling dust
and making me feel like an over consumer
yeah but how would you felt if you spent
more on shoes you loved and more
comfortable
really happy i mean when you say it like
that sure but i mean maybe you spent
more and maybe you only bought two or
three shoes that this year right well
it's it's also the digitization of all
of this it's so easy to buy now because
i just give my phone my face id and
suddenly my credit card is charged
and that satisfaction you get that
instant gratification you get from that
i mean hit yeah yeah but it's not really
sustainable one for your happiness yeah
and two for even for our economy because
i mean maybe you would have enjoyed more
going to a nice store trying on a bunch
of shoes picking the one that was really
comfortable again maybe it ruled out
buying like five ten pairs of shoes but
you had that wonderful shopping
experience
and you have a pair of shoes that you
actually wear right right i mean i like
the sound of having this enjoyable
experience i just don't know what i'm
gonna do without all this excess
clothing i mean i think about tvs
they've gotten cheaper as the years go
by every black friday you can get a
bigger one better quality and the price
keeps coming down chromebooks make it
accessible for everyone because for less
than a hundred dollars each kid can
actually have like a a pc
but i don't think we even appreciate how
miraculous these goods are i mean that
those flat screen tvs are a lot nicer
than those ones in the 80s people to sip
up for even a chromebook think about
what that can do compared to a mac that
cost so much more relative your
household income in the 80s yeah well it
also reminds me of like alibaba you can
access
the chinese supply chain directly and
get as much clothing or you could buy 20
of those sheen shoes for a dollar yeah i
mean it's so cheap you just have to
figure out where to put them exactly
well it reminds me speaking of that of
the stat from your story that
you only wear each garment seven times
is that right which feels honestly like
so shocking to me i'm gonna think about
that every time i'm in a fitting room
now will i wear this seven times and if
i can't hit the average then i'm not
gonna buy it do you think with inflation
right now the way it is with prices
rising and we don't know whether it's
permanent or temporary but we haven't
seen prices rise like this in a couple
of years a couple of decades that people
will be more attuned to saving to buy
the right thing or wait well they just
buy now for fear that if they don't buy
it now it's going to keep going in price
well that's how inflation becomes uh
permanent right is people rush out to
buy more because they're worried prices
are going to go up so it's so fulfilling
it becomes self-fulfilling i mean this
is the danger this is why i never really
quite understood the transitory
distinction because any inflation
becomes
all inflation starts it's transitory
right but whether or not it takes hold
and becomes permanent depends on how
much it factors in people's expectations
allison this is so interesting thank you
so much for for kind of sharing your
thoughts on this because it's something
that people think about a lot but they
don't always say right out loud we
always feel guilty about this deep down
and you're actually giving us the advice
for how to tackle it
snack yes please okay so we just
returned from our american consumption
tour
what is your biggest takeaway scar after
our experience there's a big gap between
what we want and what we need so the
pandemic has made really clear that we
can't always get what we want when we
want it and at the price we want yeah
because prices have been increasing yeah
so we have to kind of rethink what we
want versus what we need and
i kind of liked how it was before with
before the pandemic came along and
ruined everything where you could go out
on experience and spend your time and
your money on doing something as opposed
to
acquiring something physical right
that's going to hurt the environment and
cause all these backlogs of issues with
the supply chain you don't really want
anyway and after you know two days or
five days you're looking at it you're
like take some space and that's my
biggest takeaway is to be much more
intentional about my shopping because i
tend to buy in bulk and just think oh
i'll return it but then i was looking
this up because i figured i'm not alone
after we were at bingers and there were
so many return items there
3.5 billion products are returned every
year in the u.s 5 billion pounds of
returns end up in landfills oh my gosh
so it's a lot of waste when you're
buying with returning in mind as your
plan of action which is kind of what i
always do and just a small tiny sliver
of that ends up in a place like binge or
bargain bins yep so that gets kind of
recycled into the economy but everything
else is just left for dead yeah exactly
exactly so i guess again it's like be
deliberate right be deliberate and maybe
technology can help solve some of our
problems right because the amazon buy
now button made it so easy for us to get
things but you know now with nfts and
with digital and virtual goods and the
metaverse maybe we spend our money on
virtual things as opposed to physical
things yeah like you said more
deliberate i like that yeah you know i
will give the gift of my attention to to
you or to anyone else yes yes we'll give
each other the gift of our mutual
attention
happy holidays everyone
[Music]